Hello.
Yes, is this Denish?
Yes.
How are you?
It's Frank Defratus.
Oh, hello, how are you?
Very good.
It's really good to talk to you.
Yeah, nice to talk to you.
I had I had been thinking about you quite a bit before I received the your email and I found that such a coincidence.
And uh I wanted to ask you to come on the show uh to talk about the work that you enjoy have been doing with Triple Take.
You know, get a little bit of your history and and also uh I'm sure people would be very interested in hearing about the products that you create, where they're available and I also understand you create some DCG plates that are available too.
That's right, yeah.
Uh we make uh we make them up uh as and when we get the order because DCG plates don't last very long.
Yeah.
And uh so basically what we say is that you get the maximum benefit of them for the first ten days or so.
Then they start uh dying off, but they're still usable for another two weeks.
But after about uh three and a half, four weeks, uh you'll still get an image, but it will be uh much lower quality.
The image will be dimmer and the image green shifts.
Are they available or uh as red sensitive?
Uh no, I've never made them.
Uh I've never made them with a die.
Uh I know that uh I sent off some plates to someone called Tom B.
uh in Canada who said he was going to try them with a dye, but I never heard anything back about them.
Oh, okay.
So yes, you can put uh a dye in them to make them red sensitive.
You can even do that after you've sensitized it by just doing it in the dark.
Yeah.
Uh but I've never tried it.
But pr the problem is it takes long the exposure is very, very long.
Yeah.
Uh so uh e even with green it's fairly long or or blue.
Well uh with uh four eighty eight it's not too bad.
And five one four it gets a little long, but at these uh five three two with these dialed lasers, it is very long because you're right at the bottom of the of the uh sensitivity curve.
So so with with a red Heaney you could go away for the weekend and uh come back and Well not that bad but you could certainly go away have lunch and come back.
Yeah.
The the the four eighty eight that's he CAD isn't it?
No Argon.
Argon laser.
Okay.
You don't see many he CADs around anymore.
Not uh for I mean they are at the bottom of dot matrix machines.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Yeah I I I know Doug Miller used to use them in Philadelphia.
There was a place um oh jeez, what was the name of it uh I'm I'm forgetting about it.
It was right down on Delaware Avenue.
And uh Douglas Miller holographic design, I know they did uh dichromated uh work right in the basement there, right down by the river in Philadelphia and they were using uh a he CAD laser down there, yeah.
Yeah, because I mean the the the peak of the sensitivity at DCG is in the U V around about three fifty.
Yeah.
So as you get more and more into the uh uh into four hundred uh it it you get better and better sensitivity.
Uh but you also get increased noise.
Well you know what you're a real old timer with holography, aren't you?
Yeah, I I've been in it since nineteen eighty one.
I I started off as a as an intern with Richmond holographics.
Mhm.
Uh I st I did their uh one week course.
Uh and then uh Edwina discovered that I knew a little bit about the physics and engineering of lasers and holography.
So she made me a deal that uh uh if I came in there and worked with them as a consultant uh that I could have table time in return.
Uh and then uh she recruited Peter Miller to be their uh teacher there uh uh to teach the holography course and Peter Miller recruited me as his assistant.
Yeah.
So I I morphed from becoming a technical consultant to becoming Peter Miller's assistant.
And Peter Miller sort of introduced pseudocolour to England.
So he uh so I was helping him work with pseudocolour back then in eighty one I think that was eighty two very beautiful work out of uh Richmond holographics.
I'm sorry?
Very beautiful work.
Oh yeah yeah well I mean they they ha they really got that pseudocolour thing down the white reflections that they did back then are are really nice.
Yeah.
M one of my favorite holograms of theirs the uh it was a pulse piece but wasn't pseudocolour.
It was uh Lindau man.
Oh yes.
Yes.
I love that.
Uh yeah that that that is a very nice piece.
So you you worked for a few other companies of on the British Museum for that.
Yes.
Say that again I'm sorry I think I overstared I believe they were commissioned by the British Museum because the actual Lindau man was too delicate to be taken around to the different museums.
So they commissioned uh Richmond to make a hologram of it which could be sent around.
Yeah.
You know that that does that's another application which in theory seems like a wonderful application for holography but it's still something that you don't see happen quite often with museums.
No well the Russian pieces back then in the exception, yes and they did some wonderful work with that emulsion.
Yeah, when pieces from U.S.
available in the West back then.
Yeah.
Uh but you're right, you don't see them very often.
Uh I think partly because it's uh when color techniques become better and better, uh I think that uh you'll get you'll see more and more of them.
Well this this is certainly in your blood, isn't it?
Oh, absolutely.
Yeah.
And in theoretical physics you require a lot of imagination and a lot of imagery.
And when I found holography, it was the perfect uh thing for me because it requires the the imagination, but it also requires that sense of imagery, that sense of being able to see something.
So it fit like a glove.
Yeah, I don't want to go off on this uh part of holography, but I'm I'm sure with your background in theoretical physics and probably touching on philosophy as well, you're aware of uh the writings of s uh folks sort of uh such as uh Krishnamurti and some of the other ones.
Boom was actually I took a course on really I was in uh class with Boom on uh on this whole concept of uh the holographic universe.
Well you've you've touched on just about everything.
Now you you were in England for a while and then you decided to come over to the States, I guess.
I came over uh in eighty six without any particular intent in mind because in England around then there was no real technical holography.
There was a lot of small art studios.
Yeah.
And I was working with icon holographics with Cave and that folded.
So uh uh Carvey suggested I come to America because he said there's a lot more technical work going on here in America.
Yeah.
So I basically just got the next plane out of England and ended up in in LA.
But then I talked to the Arkansas and they suggested I try a company called NTS, National Technical Systems.
Yeah.
And National Technical Systems had a contract to make eye protection goggles for the army.
So I got absorbed into that and uh I got uh so that was my first job here was basically uh notch filters.
Yeah.
Uh the Arkin brothers Bob and Bill and Bob.
Okay.
Uh they've been here for forever.
They they repair lasers and uh they they sell secondhand lasers I believe.
Is that Joy in the background?
I'm sorry?
Yes yes hello.
Hello Joy, how are you?
I'm good.
For for many many years ago you were not that far away from me globally speaking when you were I wish I'd known about you at the time.
Like home in college, right?
Yeah.
Well she had the same problem I did, uh that we couldn't find holographers.
Uh-huh uh when I I first came here on vacation around eighty one or eight or eighty two after I finished the Richmond course and uh I asked around and nobody knew what holography was where they were or anything at all about them.
Yeah I happened to find uh Nancy Goglione completely by accident.
Mm-hmm.
And Nancy Goglioni then uh told me about the whole off gallery and then from the whole offs gallery I met the whole holographic community.
But had it not been for that one accident to meet Nancy uh I would never have known and Joy had the same problem.
Yeah.
Yeah I started my studio here in eighty three.
Ah I had been following holography for a number of years, you know, when the museum opened on Mercer Street in the mid seventies, I guess it was, you know museum.
But uh I w just local, you know, I mean I never really reached out.
Then I started a newsletter which I sent out to an a lot a lot of people around the world in the eighties.
But it was very much a struggle as I'm sure you're aware.
Oh sure.
And um my the the hours are just you know incredible.
You're you know sometimes c finishing stuff up two, three o'clock in the morning.
That's even if you have stuff to do.
Yeah.
Well yeah well I mean even then uh besides the Richmond course I uh I I basically started up in my father's garage building my own sand table with Fred's book.
Oh yeah.
And uh that was the only way and uh to to learn how to do it.
There was nobody around you could ask anything off.
Well I I had I had three my wife and I had three daughters so I had to do everything that would come down to pi I even did holographic birthday parties.
I I would travel to play other states.
I go down to Delaware, Maryland.
It it didn't make any difference, you know if someone wanted a holographic birthday party I'd I'd pack up the laser 'cause you know P some people don't want clowns and things like that.
They want educat this is when the um uh when the home schooling was starting to boom.
You know, so they wanted more educational type of uh birthday parties for their kids.
So I'd go down, I'd have laser light little laser light show, I'd lasers, holograms.
So you have to do everything.
You know I mean you're I mean even today you have to do pretty much everything.
Uh uh you have to be your own laser technician.
You have to be your own model maker.
Yeah.
Uh you're you're a very very interesting guest because you've made that leap and and both you and Joy are out there.
You know, I mean you're out there.
This this is what you know you depend on.
It's it's not like you know, if if something's not happening this week with holography, you know, you've got your check coming in from the other job.
Sure.
You know, and uh Well, holography is a very tough business to be in.
Uh there have been so many people who've given up on it.
Oh, there people the the problem is people would spend more than a million trying to make a million.
Mm-hmm.
That's what it is.
And uh uh I mean I've been trying to try uh look into why that is, why holography companies aren't doing well.
And uh one of the conclusions I've come to is that the public does not understand it.
Uh and so if you see if you try to tell them about holography, there's no way to advertise it.
Yeah.
Uh and you can't really uh you're basically uh stuck with making a lot of holograms on your own time and then showing those around.
Yeah, and and when they and when they do cover it for you, so if you get an article in a newspaper or something, a lot of times they're not explaining holography the way that it should be in the first place.
You know, so it's different.
Yes.
Yeah.
It isn't you mean this you mean it isn't?
Uh I wish it were.
Yeah, we're still saying twenty years.
Yeah.
Twenty years ago.
Saying twenty years.
What is it?
Benton said three PhDs away?
Three PhDs.
That's pretty good.
I think he's talking about holographic TV though.
Well you all have a a whole line of products that you produce.
Why don't you take a little little time to uh uh I will have a link to your website for all the HoloTalk listeners.
Okay.
And uh tell us about the products that you put together and each of your responsibilities as far as getting those products to market.
Well, the initial idea that we started off with was that all the holographers that we talked to, all the commercial uh business holographers that we talked to, uh said that the moment you say holograms or holographics to a client, they would immediately turn off.
They would either think that you were in fantasy land uh uh or that uh it just was way too expensive for them.
So uh what we thought we would try was was the idea of producing um a product and object that is an everyday common common garden product or object that everyone uses, uh but it would be uh it would have a hologram on it.
So that the hologram would be an additional feature to something that you would get anyway.
And so uh we thought things like coasters, clocks, uh keychains, the common stuff that I suppose a lot of other people have done.
Uh but then uh we had this idea of putting it against stained glass and creating a more decorative product.
Mm-hmm.
And so we made a lot of these things uh and we tried to come up with new ideas like uh uh a little medallion c hanging off a chain on a on a metal hook, that kind of thing.
And so we have a lot of the uh a lot of those around.
Uh and then we also thought about logos and things like that.
Uh but that did not seem to be going too well.
Uh we put it up on the on the on the website uh and we tried to publicize it.
But we also then uh got requests through technical holograms.
Mm-hmm.
And so now we are actually getting more and more into technical holograms and less and less into the display stuff, uh unless someone uh wants display holograms.
D define what you're doing with tech if you can what you're doing with uh technical.
What we're doing is basically using uh holograms to create dedicated optical setups.
Uh if you for example uh want uh uh a a ho an optical lens or an optical mirror that only has like a notch filter something like that.
Uh you have companies coming to us and they say I want this particular optical function and so the two of us sit down try to figure out how to record a hologram such that you get that optical function and then we make a sample, give it to them we take a photograph, we show them the photograph and we say here is the hologram you can see that when you hit it with white light uh you get rings of different colors expanding outward maybe something like that.
And and for the sake of the listeners, what would the application of such a product be for a company?
Uh well it uh filters for filtering out selective wavelengths from uh a particular source uh that's good.
Something like that.
Yeah.
Uh solar collectors uh now you you also offer workshops that people can come to your studio and learn holography as well, right?
Well yes we uh Paloma College approached us uh they have an adult education uh section and they approached us and we uh have had two three two sets of students so far.
Uh so we take in students, we uh take them right from uh theory, we spend the first morning basically going over the theory of phallography and then we sp uh spend the uh uh second half of the first day showing them just basically making a laser transmission H1.
And we do it all and they simply watch and then on the second day it's a two day course on the second day uh we make a single beam Dennis check in the morning and we have them set the optics under our supervision.
Yes.
Uh and they get to take home the uh the single beam Dennis check and then on the afternoon of the second day we set up an H1 H2 system uh to do reflection H one H two with the H1 they made the previous uh day and this time again they set up all the optics from scratch.
Yeah and so they get to take home uh single beam Dennis check and an image blade uh reflection and their H1.
Yeah what plates are you using now?
Uh now we're using DCG for these students we use uh silver halite because we don't want the students exposed to the Albin laser it's too powerful.
So we use uh a low power Hini and we use PFGO one on the finding you get very good results with those we get some very very bright ones.
Uh we've got uh silver halide holograms that are almost as good as DCG.
Uh and they can be seen in ordinary light under a fluorescent bulb uh without blacking.
Well what do you think of the fact that sometimes regardless of what it is that people are doing in this field that sometimes people get really good results with something and other times people can't do it if their life depended on it or something in between.
I mean in the consistency across uh people you know amateurs, hobbyists and I I I I guess there's more consistency where professionals are concerned, but as far as you know, this this amateur realm that's the the that's growing by leaps and bounds.
Yeah.
Because I think that partly it's very, very procedural, but you have no feedback on the process.
So you have to you have no idea of how well you're doing until you get to the end of the process.
So if your laser happens to be fluttering, if something happens to be moving, you won't know that until you've done your shot.
Once you've done your shot, you look at it, you have to basically think backwards of all the different ways that could have gone wrong and check every one of them out.
Yeah.
And so it's a it's a fairly complicated process, but so long as the equipment is working and the process is consistent, you should get good consistent results.
Yes.
But because there are so many unknowns, it's very difficult to get to that process, I think.
I think a lot of the time uh and again, I think there's a lot of misinformation out there.
There are books that tell you simply point your laser at the glass, put an object behind it, turn on the shutter and you get a hologram.
And when they don't you have what Bob has called hobby killers.
They think they've done something wrong and they give up on it.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
With it.
And if you just carefully go through uh all your equipment and all your procedures, you should get consistent holograms every time.
I I find that holograms will talk to you if you learn how to listen to them once they're finished.
Well, one of the most difficult things that I had to do was trying to uh troubleshoot a hologram by looking at the image.
I mean, clearly if the image is dark, you know you've done something wrong.
But one of the most difficult things I have to do is if there's a little ring on the image or if there's a fading off, if there's uh a vignetting, you have to basically work backwards and say, Is it the laser, is it my optics?
Did a uh did a baffle get in the way?
And and that troubleshooting is a ta is a talent all of its own, I thought.
Have you ever worked with stereograms?
Never.
No.
That's a demanding process.
Oh, I bet it is because you have to do three hundred shots and if one frame goes That's it.
You start all over again.
I've heard horror stories that way.
Yeah.
So what do you see for the future for triple take?
Um I'm I I like display holography.
I'm hoping that we get a better market out of display holography.
Uh but unfortunately I don't see it as a very big uh part of of of uh a sales.
So I see more and more technical uh work and I think that uh holography is coming into its own it's becoming very very strong in the technical area.
It's being called diffractive optics now, DOEs.
And this whole field of DOEs, especially with telecommunications, uh is becoming very big.
And so I think that more and more we're going to have to get into that area.
Micro optics uh micro optics uh fiber brag gratings uh optical routers uh the internet when internet do comes out there's going to be a big push for optical uh interconnects yeah and uh with uh with these uh uh WDMs which are basically holographic uh there's there's going to be a big push for holography in that area I think.
Is there anything that you'd like to say that I haven't asked about uh I can't think of anything offhand.
Uh I would uh uh I would promote holography by getting more and more amateurs involved in it and and showing it around.
I think that the more the public at large gets to see a holograms, the more accepted it will be.
Uh so I'd like to see more holograms.
In the eighties there were a large number of public showings uh in London and over here and that's all gone.
So I'm kind of I'd like to be able to set up a gallery somewhere in San Diego, uh get holographers to send me holograms and make our own holograms and have public showings m uh so that the public at large gets to see them more.
That would be very nice.
I used to do that back in the eighties.
Right, and it's it's very well received.
Sure.
It is but it doesn't go anywhere.
Yeah, yeah.
It's very well received.
There were several shows that I had uh curated uh back oh I don't know, maybe m between eighty five and ninety five.
Uh between you know, this area, southeastern Pennsylvania, New Jersey, New York area.
Um very well received.
One of them had people out the door and down the block.
Really waiting to get in to see holograms.
Right, right.
Uh the uh the uh but that's it.
Nothing happens.
Now is that that could be my fault because I because I didn't didn't have I don't think maybe perhaps I don't have the the the experience to take it any further, you know, w what do you do?
I mean, correct ways of marketing, coming up with good ideas to do this or do that or business ideas or whatever.
Well, I think that one of the problems that I found in a lot of those shows that happened in the eighties was that there was no follow through during the show.
You go to an artist gallery, uh you see the artist's name and you have some way of contacting the artist, some way of finding out more about that particular artwork.
And I suppose one of the B's in my bonnet is that if you see a hologram from anything from a magazine cover to let's say uh a display piece advertising something, you have no concept or idea of who made that hologram or how it was made.
There's no follow through.
Yeah.
And so I thought what I would like to do is if I were to ever do this public showing thing, is to have some way of contacting other holographers so that when a holographer sends me a hologram, I'll have a little card giving his or her contact information, some idea of how you can get to make your own hologram, where the schools are a complete kind of information package so that people who see these holograms can then know where to go to find out more to learn how to do it themselves, what the history of the subject is, that kind of thing.
And and I think that was the problem then is they came in, they saw the holograms, they said this is great, walked home and didn't follow through.
And that was it.
Yeah.
That was it.
And well keep me in mind if you want a hologram I could certainly send you one if you ever wanted to put something on display if you got something together out there.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah I'm I'm still working my way through that but it's uh because I know that gallery space is not easy to come by.
You can't just go to a gallery and say I'd like to put up holograms.
You have to sell the concept to uh but yes thank you.
If uh if and when I ever set that up I let I'll I'll uh contact you.
And thank you for coming on the show.
Well thank you.
Joy I'd like to get you on for a a specific show as well to hear about your background especially uh your involvement with women in optics and how you know you you had chosen the field of physics as part of your uh part of your education in your uh field of work.
Yeah.
I was figuring that you were in view interviewing him separately because his background is so different from mine.
Well, we'll we'll get a separate interview with you up there.
Okay.
You know.
That'd be fun.
Yeah.
All right.
It's uh a little after three o'clock in the afternoon here and time to wrap up for the weekend.
Uh I have to do the second part of that holographic stamps uh that I have up there.
That's uh holographic stamps.
Yeah, uh it's uh it's a program that I've worked on with uh Hans.
And uh the history of uh holographic postage stamps, Philatelli.
Oh so that's up there.
Part one's up there now, and I have to get part two up there f and then I have uh one show after that, and I think probably two weeks from now yours will go up.
Oh, okay.
We're actually in your part of the world every Christmas.
So we were saying this morning that uh come Christmas we might as well pop over.
How close are you?
Yeah, my family's from Philadelphia, so that's where I go home every every year for Christmas.
No kidding.
I grew up in Philly.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know if you could tell by the uh Philly accent.
Yes again.
Sylvester Stallone Rocky uh type of thing.
Learn learning to speak proper English was like learning a second language from me growing up in Philly.
Uh huh.
Well the difference of between American English and British English, I'm still working my way through that.
Yeah.
Well thank thank you both.
And uh y I don't know if you're on the email list or not that goes out to people when new shows go up or not, but uh yeah, you can get that at the website or um I'll actually just uh send me send you an email separately.
Great, alright.
Okay.
There's there's eight years of programming.
This this show's in its eighth year now and uh Yes, I know, I've been following it.
Yeah.
We have gone on and listened from time to time.
Oh, that's nice to know.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So y so you're the ones.
All right.
Thank you.
Have a nice weekend.
You too.
Okay, bye.
Bye.